and finally new rule before summer is
over Donald Trump must give everyone a
vacation from himself you know you know
July used to be a happy month for me it
was my downtime a chance to tend my
garden and then smoke it but this July
started with tanks in the streets of
America another notch in my dictator
checklist then came Trump telling for
Congress women to go back where they
came from you know chick sylvania by the
time he got to know humid want to live
in Baltimore I got to hi the fire
department had to come get me down
when your vacation leaves you more
exhausted than when it started
that's called Trump fatigue and I'm not
the only one who suffers from it 70% of
Americans say Trump tweets too much and
70% find him unpresidential that's the
fatigue talking even as TV ratings are
failing in June he did a primetime
interview on ABC and got only 3.9
million viewers a sharp drop from
celebrity Family Feud which got 6.1
million in the same timeslot the week
before but not sad for Democrats fatigue
is the best thing we've got going for us
the majority of Americans aren't tired
of winning their title looking at his
fat [ __ ] face do you have any idea
how obnoxious you have to come across to
have only a 43% approval rating when the
unemployment rate is under four yeah
it's hard to beat an incumbent in a good
economy every incumbent since FDR has
won if they avoided a recession leading
up to the election year and consumer
confidence is sky-high Americans have
disposable income
it's a bullish market lobbyists who used
to just lease a congressman are now
buying
the voters that Democrats need to win
moderates who have Trump fatigue will
vote against the good economy I think
just to get back to normalcy but they
won't trade it away for left-wing
extremism you say you want a revolution
well you know you gotta get elected
first in this election and this election
is about two things fatigue and fear we
have fatigue he has fear fear of
socialism fear of open borders fear of
getting rid of private health insurance
fear of higher taxes he's running on the
communists are coming [ __ ] yourself we
should run on elect me and we can stop
talking about him
all the Democrats have to do to win is
to come off less crazy than Trump and of
course they're blowing it coming across
his unserious people who are going to
take away all your money so migrants
from Honduras can go to college for free
and get a major in America sucks
now do I want Biden to be president not
really but bite is the only Democrat who
beats Trump in Ohio
he's like non-dairy creamer nobody loves
it but in a jam it gets the job done
I can't figure people out but they just
like Joe
maybe it's the familiarity he's like a
McDonald's when you're in Europe I'm
sick of hearing that Democrats need to
excite the base Trump excites the base
with Obama the battle cry was yes we can
with trumpets what the [ __ ] he generates
the kind of excitement that could put
the Dalai Lama on klonopin it's the
fatigue stupid let's make it hard for
Trump to play on voters fears and let
the fatigue win the election for us
we'll get to the revolution
but remember put on your oxygen mask
before assisting your child
if the Democrats can do that and win
this country might stop being as divided
as it is because underneath maybe we're
not so divided old town road just set a
record for the most weeks ever at number
one and it's a black guy wrapping a
country song on a horse and he's gay
the rapper not the horse gay country rap
you can't get a bigger tent than that
you